let's look at the latest i mean it's
like to call it a conspiracy theory
is almost like too much because it
suggests there's some
theory and there really isn't a news max
reporter
suggested during a recent white house
press briefing
that the entire delta variant might be
almost like a false flag it might not
really be a thing
this took place during an outrageously
chaotic
press briefing um this press briefing so
let me set this up for you because
the entire scene was absolute and total
bedlam
jensaki did not hold this press briefing
this press briefing was held by the
deputy press secretary karine
jean-pierre who did
overall a very good job um towards the
end of the press conference
there was this idea they do this every
once in a while they'll bring on a
reporter via video conference to ask a
question sometimes it's like a rural
reporter once it was someone from alaska
um okay so they try to bring on this
reporter remotely
and there's just massive technical
issues like we the viewers at home could
hear the reporter
but i guess in the room they couldn't
hear the reporter
and then the reporter was talking at the
same time
newsmax reporter starts talking about
the delta variant and it gets nuts so
i'm still wondering why newsmax is even
in the white house press briefing room i
never i still can't fully understand
how that works we've heard before oh
someone has lost a seat
but they're still in there at the back
yelling questions it's not totally
transparent to me there's some opacity
here okay
but let's get to it and again i'm
warning you it's total and complete
chaos in the room like it's really hard
to figure out what's going on and what's
even being said
but let's make an attempt to figure it
out when
that is the dominant strain in the area
when people just test whether they're
currently collapsing
we don't we don't okay so the question
there
and by the way i don't know if you saw
seems to so so far
the mask is off the nose and soon you'll
see the mask actually come all the way
down
the question is how can you say the
delta variant is spreading
when when people get tested it's just
are you positive or are you negative for
covid that's the question it's all sort
of like
is is the delta variant even really a
thing
people just test whether they're covered
but we don't we don't
we don't test the we don't test it we
listen to public
wealth and scientists and they tell us
that
i mean that's what they are telling us i
laid out why
i laid out how contagious it was and i
laid out why
uh why we needed to have this this is
this is so frustrating i'm with you guys
i laid out a lot of what the answers we
get is because they say so
without a lot of well they're the
experts it's not it's not just day
so
uh i i guess what she's saying is
how do we know if something is the delta
variant if i have symptoms and i go and
get tested
and it's sir you're positive right sir
sure i how does is it delta or is it not
delta
the the explanation is you sequence
the virus you get a cohort that's
representative of the population
and you test them and you sequence the
virus you don't do this with everybody
and sort of like in when you when you do
a political poll
you don't interview every american you
get a representative sample and so the
idea would be if 40
of the sample believes something then
you can extrapolate that roughly 40
percent of the country believe something
if your sample is good
it's the same thing with the sequencing
the their their
test cohorts and if they see that 80
percent of the test cohort
is the delta variant then you can say
well delta's probably 80 percent of the
country's
positive tests generally speaking if
your sample is good like she seems to be
saying why isn't karine jean-pierre
explaining epidemiology to her so
therefore it must all be some kind of
false flag
it continues these are scientists these
are experts
i just said that hold on one second hold
on one second i just said that dr
lewinsky
said just recently in her 20-year
career she had never seen a a variant
that was so contagious
so this is 20 years of her career i
actually don't think karine jean-pierre
is doing that great of a job here
unfortunately
so this is absolutely absolutely
a major major problem that we are trying
to deal with that's why we heard from
the president yesterday
that's why we keep talking about people
need to get vaccinated
so that is that is the that is the way
that we're trying to move in this
demonstration making sure that
we are protecting uh people here making
sure that we're dealing with this
pandemic
in a way that is effective and that's
how we're going to move forward i'll
take another question
so you know there's i mean what's
frustrating about this is
first of all it doesn't really matter
what you call it
like whatever you call it even if you
don't even talk about variance
it has gotten way more contagious
call it whatever you want you don't need
to sequence
every case you need to sequence a
representative sample if you want to say
wow delta's now dominant in florida
you're not sequencing every individual
you're saying let's take a cohort and it
used to be that 5
of the cohort was delta and now 80 so
that it's becoming dominant the logic
here from the reporter is sort of like
if you've not exactly explained how
gravity works then i should be able to
fly like maybe people can fly because
you're not explaining to me exactly how
gravity works if you've not tested
gravity it maybe it doesn't actually
apply here maybe it's made up
and karine's expression you know it's
funny it's sort of like a combination of
confusion and pure hatred
it would have been better for her to be
a little more prepared because
to you and me we're like oh my god it's
like this is not an epidemiology
briefing
we're we're testing a cohort and and
that's sort of
it to the conspiracy theorists
that comes off like the newsmax reporter
made a really good point
and there's this incredible arrogance in
there about like
if the newsmax reporter doesn't
understand it
how could anyone and therefore is it
even definitely
true and it's like a combination of
belief based on ignorance
and dunning-kruger they don't understand
the science
they assume that they do and therefore
they they assume that if the science was
good they would understand it
but they don't and so when they
encounter some kind of
uh information that challenges their
preconceptions or they don't get it like
what
you get a positive or a negative when
you get tested so how could we know
anything about delta
um then all of a sudden it reinforces
their beliefs that they shouldn't
trust what's going on you know it's sort
of like hey
karine can you explain the field of
epidemiology in the press briefing room
oh you can't well then there must be no
delta and with a lot of this
you know it's it's like start from the
the way i would suggest dealing with
people like this in your private life
and we've talked about this before start
from are you open to the idea
that you might not know everything and i
might not know everything oh okay good
if if if you're open to that then we can
go to the next thing
what reason do you have to doubt that
there is a different
variant now than at the beginning like
do you have general doubt about the fact
that viruses change over time
do you have specific doubt about how
this
right and really try to break down where
the disconnect is but
everything just seems totally confusing
to this reporter she doesn't know how to
wear a mask it shouldn't shock us that
she also doesn't
understand you test a cohort and then
you extrapolate from it
it's it's really a sad state of affairs
my friends not sad is the fact that we
are now under two weeks from our 16th
anniversary
16 years since the start of the david
pakman show
we'll be doing a one-day membership
special on monday august 16th
i would love for you to sign up on that
day it's going to be an incredible day
it's going to be an historic day
you can sign up for our newsletter at
davidpakman.com
and then monday morning on the 16th
you'll get an email telling you how to
sign up at a
huge discount one of our sponsors is
geology
the place to go for men's skin care
geology helps men find
a simple skin care routine that works
it's personalized for you
by a dermatologist and geology can help
with
dark puffy eyes acne oily skin
protecting your skin against damage you
answer a few questions about your skin a
dermatologist will design
a personalized skin regimen for your
needs
you'll get a 30-day trial with the
products they recommend to try them out
if you like how it goes they'll keep
sending it to you
these aren't bogus miracle creams
these are just the clinical
evidence-based products that
dermatologists have at their disposal
but they're tailored personally to you
based on the products you really need
i took the quiz a couple of months ago
their dermatologist
matched me with a regimen that's just
great for me
i've been happy with the results my
skin's looking great i can actually see
a difference
go and take geology's free quiz and when
you use my link
right underneath this video you will
save
up to 40 percent off your first paid
month